uh I can see asan who's a fourth year EC
engineering student from Hyderabad so
welcome everyone thank you so much for
joining it's fantastic to have you all
on board I can see Manoj has joined from
Delhi I can see jaganathan is joining
from Bangalore and a lot of
introductions coming in so please do
introduce yourself from the chat here we
would love to know where are you joining
us from and your name as well sometimes
you're not able to make out your name
from your email ID so that's why and uh
why not nwork a bit before we start this
event free interview prep master class
so before we start let me just quickly
take you through the ground rules we
have here so if you have any question
for our speaker here today who amanpuri
has already joined us you can put down
your questions in the Q&A box uh the
session is being recorded in case you
want to go through the recording of the
session again you can expect a followup
email with recording link webinar
certificate and also bonus offer for
attending the webinar now what ex what
exactly is the bonus offer here so the
bonus offer is for of the program uh
which will be talking about by IAT goari
towards the end of the session and uh
you will be getting a bonus offer for
attending this webinar so that's pretty
interesting uh in case you want to uh
request approve of attendance for this
webinar uh you can enter your full name
in the post webinar survey so you can do
that so uh that is the name that will be
going into the webinar certificate so
please do help us with that in case
you're looking for the webinar
certificate of this event and also uh
this program is powered by simply Lear a
world's number one online Bo Camp uh we
are very proud that we have been
transforming lives by empowering people
VI are digital skills in over last 13
years here and U we have advanced over
five lakh plus careers we have been in
basically over 150 plus countries uh we
have 800 plus qualified trainers uh we
have categories of courses ranging from
AI machine learning data science
business analytics cyber security cloud
computing devops project management and
many more categories which we have in
the section so uh let me quickly take
you through the agenda and once again
welcome everyone I saw a lot lot of
introductions coming in while I was uh
just quickly taking you to the ground DS
here and uh once again welcome everyone
so I'm Rasha Khan I your host for
today's webinar and I'm really excited
to be here and uh Loving You
introductions which are coming on chat
uh folks who have just joined us right
just right now we are just starting the
session you have joined just right on
time and uh we'll be going through the
agenda of the session now so we'll be
starting with getting to know a little
bit more about you how we can help you
out in your career and uh we'll be
taking you through the interview prep
master class uh where you can learn the
winning formula to a cloud devops
interview with Fang companies uh then
we'll be taking you through the program
introduction uh of I Gatti's Cloud plus
devops program and also the enrollment
steps of the program so in case you have
any questions for folks who have just
joined right now you can put down your
question in the Q&A box we'll try to
take as many questions as possible but
this is a interview prep s of webinar so
I think we'll focus on the speaker here
who actually will have a lot of things
to share with you so um before we start
I just have a quick poll question for
you as I told you that we'll be getting
to know a little bit more about you
before we start so I'll just launch this
quick poll here where we would love to
know how many years of experience do you
currently have now when I talk about
experience here I'm talking about work
experience in general so you can see
four quick options here uh the first one
is currently studying second one 0 to
three years of experience third one 3 to
5 years of experience and the last one
more than five years from now so folks
who have just joined right now we are
just starting the session and we're
starting with getting to know a little
bit about you so uh we would love to
know how many years of experience do you
currently have so this gives us a better
idea about you know folks who are
joining us come from very different
different experiences so that's pretty
interesting actually uh and uh this is
this will give us an idea as well uh
basically uh in which direction to take
uh the interview P master class as well
the speaker will have a better idea
about the kind of experience you folks
have awesome uh someone has replied on
the chat as well so that's great uh I'll
just give 10 seconds more because as I
was speaking uh folks have already
shared the responses on the poll here
most of them so that's great we have
gotten a really active set of here so I
think I'll just give 10 seconds more for
the poll here before we move
on okay okay I think uh a lot of new
folks are joining in right now uh we are
just starting the session and uh we're
just doing a quick poll here just to
know how many years of experience do you
currently have so I think I'll just five
give five seconds more for the poll here
because I see most of the folks have
already shared their responses so 5 4 3
2 1 one let me quickly end the poll and
also share the results with you so thank
you so much for sharing uh your
experience with us so as we can see that
47% of the folks who have joined us have
more than five years of experience 28%
of the folks uh have zero to three years
of experience and 16% of the folks are
currently studying 8% of the folks have
3 to 5 experience so a lot of experience
folks here that is all that is all I can
say so thank you so much again uh for
sharing that with with us now moving on
as I mentioned earlier that we already
have our speaker here with us amanpuri
so Amon would first of all would like to
welcome you uh to the interview prep
master class and would like to thank you
for taking the time out uh and you know
um basically taking us to this interview
prep master class we are very excited
for the session here and uh would love
to know your introduction for the crowd
here thank you so much Rasha I hope I'm
audible to the quum here yes yes yeah
thank you hi so I hope everyone's doing
well I was very surprised to see that
there are a lot of you know I mean I
generally see a lot of freshers in this
but it's also good to see a lot of
experienced folks also coming into this
and generally I don't see anyone above
or below me because I believe that we
are after all you know idtech folks and
it's just about you know uh you know
just getting to collaboration and we'll
always give some learning opportunities
to each other so really glad to know
about that so just giving my
introductions my name is Aman amanpuri
I'm A Cloud consultant at Google I
generally have more than around closing
to six and a half years of experience
now uh generally I have been more into
developing Cloud Solutions in AWS Azure
and obviously Google Cloud platform and
uh I started my role as a systems
engineer which generally if you know
most of the folks who might know in the
quum uh generally means handling you
know on Prem infrastructure or those
kinds of things but then I started to
move to my career to cloud and then
press this history with me and yeah
that's I'm just I'm try and more of my
core expertise comes into the cloud and
the more devops devop pieces which
generally you know is is actually the
subject of the day but yeah I'll be glad
to let you know about that right so yeah
glad to be
here uh thank you so much Aman for the
introduction and once again welcome uh
to the session uh so I think we'll be
starting with the interview prep Master
Class here uh where we will be covering
how you can learn the winning formula to
a cloud devops interview with fan
companies uh with our expert speaker
here amanpuri uh and before we start I
just have a quick poll question question
for you to understand why are you
attending this webinar today so let me
just quickly launch this poll here uh
this is a very quick poll where we would
like to understand why exactly are you
attending this interview prep master
class today so uh you can see four quick
options here which basically are
multiple choice questions so you can
select multiple options here because
there can be multiple reasons for
attending this webinar today right so as
you can see I'll just read out these
options for you so the first one is uh
to enhance my skills
specific to Cloud devop positions second
one master effective strategies for
answering Cloud devops related questions
third one Tor my responses to uh diverse
Cloud plus devops interview types and
the last one navigate challenging Cloud
devops scenarios and impress potential
inise so that is definitely important uh
so as I was speaking as I've mentioned
earlier that we have gotten a really
active set of folks here so as I speak
we actually already see the poll
responses here filling in so I feel like
I see that folks are really excited for
the class Aman so they are really uh
interactive here and they actually are
responding pretty quick so that's great
uh folks yeah yeah no no please goad
yeah yeah and um as I've mentioned
earlier that folks who have just joined
pretty late uh if you have any questions
for our speaker here we'll try to cover
it during the session but this is a
interview prep master class so it will
be mostly about the interview prep
master class so uh I think uh most of
the folks have already shared responses
here for the poort so let me quickly end
the poll here in 5 seconds so 5 4 3 2 1
let me quickly end the poll and also
share the results with you uh Aman and
for everyone to see uh so as we can see
we have gotten 84% of the votes for
enhanced my interview skill specific to
Cloud devop positions and 55% of the
votes are for master effective
strategies for answering Cloud devop
related questions 29% is for tailor my
responses to diverse Cloud devop
interview time types and 40% is for
navigate challenging Cloud devop
scenarios and impress potential
employees so thank you so much for
sharing that with us folks that gives a
definitely gives us a better
understanding on why exactly you are
attending the interview prep master
class today so now let's go ahead with
uh the interview prep master class on
how basically learn the winning formula
to E cloud devops interview um to uh
basically with fan companies so before
we start I think uh Comm let talk about
career paths in cloud and devops so uh
as you can see there are so many career
paths folks can take up in cloud and
devops right but I think I will start
with uh like for someone who's
completely coming from a different
background and uh there's always a
dilemma right where do you start where
do you start which career do you take up
there were so many careers so maybe you
can give us some uh understanding on
where they can start with and also maybe
take us through few of the career paths
here to start with yeah that's a very
interesting question right and uh this
is something I relate to myself because
uh while I did had some experience of
handling
infrastructures I Cloud was definitely
new to me but I'm talking this is
something during pre-o right I
essentially and maybe that was a luck
for me that I just joined to a
cloud-based role and that was just when
the co hit and that is when the whole
Cloud business boom like anything and
that was when you know companies
organizations education facilities every
every organization from small to large
to Enterprise they felt the need to go
with Cloud right yeah so that's just an
hch of it like you know how the you know
the how the cloud expertise come to this
place now when you talk about uh you
know switching to a cloud career
especially you know either you are a
fresher just coming out of college or
you might have some expertise in some
other roles like you know software
development or maybe you might have been
an infrastructure expert like me or
maybe a systems expert into
this there are many uh options at that
time to look into this right so
generally when you talk about those
roles you need to map to the right roles
into this now how do you map it now for
example can I consider a role for a
cloud architect if I'm just moving as a
person who is new to Cloud the answer is
no why because when you talk about Cloud
architect it means that you are
essentially architect solutions to
customers that requires a huge amount of
cloud experience and obviously with
someone who has already got a steep
learning curve and getting better
strategies into this so the best ways
would be to start with you know
engineering or Administration roles that
generally come with cl Cloud right when
you have to generally start with you
know developing basic Solutions you know
for in this case now in that there are
many you know verticals into this if you
are coming from an infrastructure
background where you have you know
manage on CR based infrastructure then
in that case you go generally into a
cloud Administration role or an
infrastructure Cloud engineer roles that
generally are you know the static roles
that you generally come into it or Cloud
support roles also many people may seem
oh why should I go into the support
roles because that's just like you know
stting into this case but that is
actually the best way or the best jump
start you can have into your career into
clouds because when you comes to support
when there is fire that's happening you
actually get to know you know how each
of the basic Cloud functions Works how
Cloud actually works how the basic
pieces you know you know you know work
into this case and generally you know
even in the fresher roles they ask for
you know Cloud support roles or maybe
just you know with another one or two
year roles or something like that but
you know that's one ways of doing it
another options would be if let's just
say you're from a development background
right then there are Cloud Engineers or
Cloud developers they generally go with
there you will start learning about you
know how to create Cloud native based
applications or you know how to you know
set up those kinds of things into this
case and then obviously comes off comes
the devop spee which does takes a little
bit of experience on both infrastructure
and development because that's what
DeVos means right it means that you need
to have the development skills and you
need to have infrastructure skills that
might be hard to you know J start as a
fresher but as I said for the prior two
roles if you start with some CL basic
Cloud developer or Cloud support or
cloud
investition I think that's generally a
jum start and as your you know
experience goes by you maybe you want to
become a specialist in security maybe
you want to become an architect or a
devops expert you generally start to get
it once you know you just start with
these start starting small RS yeah yeah
thank you so much Aman for taking us to
that uh as we have covered the career
paths here we can also talk about the
skills here uh you B basically you know
you need to be a cloud practitioner here
as you can see there are so many skills
here again the same dilemma right where
do you start where do you get started so
maybe you can share a comment on that as
well yeah so generally what happens is
when we see the number of options that
you need people generally get
intimidated with that oh my God there's
a lot of things to learn so what what
should I start with right so you just
don't have to become like the Jack of
all and the master of nothing right you
can take out have a select set of skills
may we start with you know the
foundational learnings like as I told
you about uh you know infrastructure
right uh you know so if you are an
infrastructure expert you generally have
certifications like the AWS Cloud
practitioner or you got the Azure Cloud
fundamentals or you got the Azure
administrator certification or you got
the Google Cloud uh Cloud digital leader
or associate Cloud engineer rules
certifications generally become a very
good jump start of you know starting and
learning in the clouds when you start
taking you know any courses or just
start learning into it you actually
learn about how the foundational things
or the fundamental things of cloud learn
into this now yes that will definitely
help you to get up toate skills to be a
cloud practi and when you actually and
this actually benefits more in cases as
a a fresher but because what happens is
that if you want to you know move into
some kind of a support role or
Administration role you know these these
kinds of things are a good jump start to
go with right and uh this is one of the
you know the reasons you know these
these options that you're see you talk
about database management you could talk
about so Services someone I think even
posted a question about database
management yes there are certain even
roles involved
uh you know where you have to be a
database administrator but that database
Administration involves in Cloud also as
well right and you just need to just
know the fundamentals and sometimes if
you already have those database skills
if you have already been experienced to
this it is not too hard to go into a
cloud database admin role as well so
yeah so everything when you talk about
Cloud starts with something that you
have learned which was non Cloud
something like in infrastructure
structure development or database or
even fundamental storage in this cases
right cloud is basically nothing but
someone else's computer that's just the
simple term of it so if you already have
those fundamentals set up then it's just
a matter of understanding the cloud
fundamentals and you should be golden
after that then you will start to get a
pace and understanding into this and
that's that's just the that's just the
all the days of it and whatever the
options that you see here every
fundamental touches upon it you know at
the start so yeah that's that's the
whole
just uh thank you so much that sounds
pretty interesting the skills you can
take up uh to be a cloud practitioner
thank you so much for taking us through
that now let's talk about preparing for
the interview here uh so as we can see
the first slide basically shows the
setting the stage for Success here so I
think before we start even talking about
the interview prep here uh for the next
15 minutes Aman would like to know your
interview experience as well with
Google okay you're actually trying to
hit the Bulls here but yeah
sure so
um one of the you know and I'll I'll
start with something with negative not
negative actually but something that is
a learning I would say uh one of the
things that people generally make a
mistake and that is actually written in
the point of research Ing and
understanding is finding the ideal job
role that is somewhere people always get
tipsy on what exactly you know the job
role there should be right and it is not
just only about the skills right it's
also about what uh level of experience
are they wanting on what are the tool
requirements they wanting on and does
your experience or your understanding of
Technologies if you're just you know
graduating from college or something you
know or if you have had a share of
experience could match up with these
rules into this cases right so generally
that research thing is very you know
very important in this case because and
because you if you do not take the right
role and the right uh you know job offer
or you could say the job role
opportunity that has been provided with
the right amount of experience and the
right skills needed which is not
reflected in the resume that you provide
you will be rejected at just the resume
screening level itself so that's one
thing that you need to see into this
right and when I say resume it does not
just means
resume or as a resume it also mean
social media profiles like LinkedIn
trust me if you if you are very much
active on LinkedIn and just posting good
technical stuff and having a good
technical profile into
this recruiters will approach you with
offers and that also includes the
finding recruiters because that's how I
got a job offer I did not even apply for
my role by the way I was approached by a
recruiter based on my LinkedIn profile
and they had ma me and then that's how I
got the interview over there so up Ling
is definitely one way into getting into
you know the interviews with them but
showcasing a good profile recruiters are
always searching for opportunities or
folks over there so it's very important
to take advantage of the new ways
recruiters are looking for you for
example as I talked about LinkedIn to
you know always showcase the best
possible into this but it also needs to
map with what you you have that actually
even you know that's something that I
pretty much covered about the second
point that is you know tailoring about
uh you know you know your resumes and
your achievements into this networking
referals yes very
important uh I will not say personally
myself I have gotten any benefits into
you know having someone into reference
into this but definitely having
connectivity is really helpful because
I've seen a lot of my colleagues you
know they have gotten in because of you
know good references good networking and
various insights or opportunities that
you see Within These and if I have a
good connectivity with you know folks on
these kind of options in this case right
so that's generally one of the things
that you need to
know and yep you need to stay updated
it's basically like you know having an
information about the new mobile that is
coming and launching every month you
have to be updated with your latest
skills if let's just say that you're
choosing a part for gcp or AWS or Azure
you know the good thing and the bad
thing about cloud is or even technology
as a thing is nothing is permanent
everything is just getting updated you
know in a matter of days weeks minutes
months right right so that's the Boon
and the curse of the whole thing that
you have to stay updated and stay
informed about what are the new things
that's happening you know with the cloud
and all these things like you know how
people were being focused on you know
the AI stuff that has been coming and
what are the M tools coming in so in
that way also you need to be relevant to
be relevant you have to be updated into
those
Technologies and the last thing that
comes is
definitely preparation is key but when
you talk about preparations and now I'm
talking something about the interview
experience because I promised rash I
would say
that this when you talk about
preparations is key is just learning
about a particular tool is the only
preparation the answer is no learning
tools is definitely one way of you know
understanding of you know if you have
experienced into this or you have
learned into tools or you have learned
the different tools or different
experience into this but uh the other
thing that you need to know is that you
also need to have an analytic approach
so what does that mean that means that
if let's just say that I give you a
solution that hey there is this thing
that's not getting viral anything like
you know some uh service or some product
it's not getting viral and I will just
ask you what are the possible reasons
that it's not getting viral and what
could be the best ways of you know you
know making it viral or what could be
the better improvements into this right
it's a very V question to ask right now
you might find this question very V
that's where the challenge
comes the answer can be wake but the
answer has to have an analytic approach
that is not there is no correct answer
to these kinds of questions you have to
also have an analytic approach that say
that okay you there is this way or maybe
some piece of the product may not be
working and you just you know you try to
maybe integrated with your chat boards
or something like that I'm just giving
some know random examples like this so
why am I saying this to you is because
with this what it helps the interviewer
to understand is it helps to understand
that how much this guy can think because
when the person or any anybody who's
working in a cloud role will have to
work with the potential customers they
will always have to have an outof box
thinking you know to provide solutions
to the customers so it will not just be
only tool Focus there's also a lot of
strategy thinking there's a lot of you
know uh ways or ganses on how to do into
this so you have to have that open mind
of thinking about what these things are
this and this is generally what you know
companies like Google even ask and
personally I experienced that and uh
that's one of the B very helpful keys
and forget even about you know fan
companies even other companies also
requires this kinds of approach so yeah
that's actually you know generally what
they want to think about yeah uh thank
you so much Aman for sharing your
experience uh I think we have talked
about how you can set the stage for
Success here of for preparing for the
interviews uh I think let's move on to
the technical part of the interviews
here so navigating the technical
evaluation here I think that is the most
important round also for clearing the
interview right maybe you can share your
thoughts here as well and
experiences so my response to this is
very similar to what I just said before
right when you talk about coding
challenges okay yeah good you have that
skills of coding you have that you know
you may know Java you may know net you
may know python you may know any XYZ
language that you may know and
definitely that's a plus point but that
is not the only point that the
interviewers are looking for as I said
before when you talk about you know
coding challenges or system designs you
also need to think about the approach
when it comes to coding it means yeah
algorithm design what are what is the
you know the logic behind you know the
code that you're using it so they they
see these things right they see
not just your technical knowledge but
they also see you know the logic with
you know which you're going behind with
you know with this technical solution
into this right or what what your
thought processes it's all about the
thought process if you talk about
technical or you talk about analytical
skills they all involve uh you know a
thought process right you have to have
problem solving skills or some thing
like that maybe that thing might not be
available but something you're just
thinking out of the box or something
that you know that it is available but
it has to be approached in a different
way or and the best way to do is that is
you know always relate to something what
you have experienced prior that has
helped me a lot in the interviews like
if I have reached to if I have faced in
my work experience if I have faced some
kind of a
problem and I have Sol it in that way
always plug that with your interview why
because in that way the interviewer
understands that yes you may have gone
with this kind of approaches even before
and you're thinking into that strategy
is solve obviously it is not always the
perfect strategy people will think that
oh that's a perfect strategy no it's not
about the perfect strategy it's just
about a good strategy or you know your
thought process of how you want to you
know get you know with these options or
coming uh you know into these kind of
options and uh yeah I mean
you know when you talk about there are
many tools available to you know
practice coding questions into this but
you also need to understand when you
come to coding questions coding
questions is not about just typing the
code coding questions is also about you
know understanding the algorithm or the
logic that you will use to solve that
use case right so that's generally what
interviewer sees when you talk about
technical skills technical skills means
that you have learned some good
technical stuff but at the same time you
know how you are using those Technic
that technical knowledge as a weapon for
you know solving customer challenges or
solving you know issues or you know even
internal or customer challenges that's
generally it's all about into this in in
that scenario
that uh R I cannot hear you my bad sorry
sorry sorry I got on mute uh say I was
saying thank you so much for taking us
to the technical interview tips here uh
so now we have covered the technical
part and also you know the how you can
set your stage for Success here with
interview tips of for fan companies but
also the behavior part also matters
right how basically you demonstrate your
soft skills also matters so can you
share a little bit of tip there as well
with us yes there is always a need of
you know that behavioral or you know
which what we say in Google called
googly
in in in your in your point right so
what does that mean it means that you
know how you are essentially taking the
approach so you so there is something
called as a star method that you see
that is something generally very much
being looked into or followed into you
know how you would you know come to a
problem that is coming to you and how
you would solve that approach into this
case right so because of that uh you
know what it helps to see that you know
now when you talk about behavioral
questions behavioral questions means
that there's always a conflict of
interest or a conflict of thought that
you will always receive in your current
experiences right but the thing is that
uh is to understand that if you have
faced any kind of challenges like these
what was your way of tackling those
things right so for example if there was
a iCal solution which maybe your
colleague did not like it or maybe your
colleague felt that you know there's a
better approach to this so the best
solution is always to meet that Common
Ground where they say that okay I am
also putting my solution because I feel
that this is a better solution but I
will always be open to what the person
in front is suggesting maybe he has a
different different perspective of my
thought I will not just be like Oh I'm
better and you know I don't care about
yourself solution so that is what the
behavioral questions come in general
right it's about you know you know
having the Diplomatic approach or you
can say the way where you also
appreciate or uh you know take feedbacks
from other persons to improve yourself
as well as understanding their
perspectives and at the same time you
need to even give your perspective as a
Solutions also because in that way they
will also understand understand what
their thought process is and they will
they can help you if and it's not always
that our solution is a good solution but
they can give us a feedback that okay
what would be the you know the right
approach or you know the right
uh of of read to do it in this case yeah
uh thank you so much Aman for taking us
to the interview prep tips here for the
master class basically how they can
learn and Ace uh the cloud devops
interview with fan companies uh I think
uh
and I will just take over the program
part here and for the folks here thank
you so much for taking the time out and
taking us through this interview P
master class and also in case they have
any questions I will definitely share
Aman's link with you uh in case you want
to get you know ask any other questions
or even follow him up you know STC up to
date you know with what he's doing so I
think I'll just take up the next part of
the program here uh before uh we move on
to the program part here so once again
thank you so so much Aman thanks thanks
Rasha and uh thanks everyone I had to
keep this short because I had something
urgent but uh I hope that you got some
tips into this and Ria will definitely
share you you know my details and yeah
we we'll connect and maybe I I can share
more details about it and hoping that we
can have another session where I'll be
more longer than thank you all
definitely definitely we are looking
forward to it uh having you more in
these webinars and more uh you know
things we can cover in cloud and devops
from your experience so thank you so
much once again Amon and here as you can
see I've quickly launched a Po Folks uh
where uh we have covered about the
career paths here the skills you can
take up in cloud computing and devops
and also the interview prep tips you
know how you can learn and Ace uh the
Fang interviews here uh with amanpuri uh
who basically is an expert from Google
but would love to know what is the
biggest challenge here when it comes to
becoming a cloud computing and Dev
experts here you're here because you're
interested obviously to Aspire this
career you are thinking about it so uh
the these are you can see four quick
options here uh this is a multiple
choice poll uh to understand what is the
biggest challenge here when it comes to
taking up the cloud devops uh career
here so I think as I was speaking uh
most of the folks have already shared
the responses here uh so I'll just give
10 seconds more for the poll here before
we move
on
also this is a multiple choice uh poll
question so you can select multiple
options here in case this poll does not
cover your responses your concern you
can let us know on the chat or in the
Q&A box as well so feel free to do that
so I think uh I see that most of the
folks have already shared responses here
so I'll just quickly end this poll in 5
seconds here so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll and and also share the
results with you folks so let's see what
folks have shared as the biggest concern
when it comes to becoming a cloud
computing devop experts here so as we
can see that 37% of the folks have voted
for my work schedule won't allow me
enough time for learning 62% of the V
which is the highest number of VES you
have gotten for I wouldn't get the
Practical exposure I need to become job
ready and 32% of the folks have voted
for I can't find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum and 16% of the
folks have voted for I find it difficult
to learn from pre-recorded videos so
thank you so much for sharing that with
us uh now let me take you uh quickly
take you through the program here uh by
IAT ghati the professional certificate
program in cloud computing and devops uh
so a little bit about the program here
this program comes with a comprehensive
uh industry aligned learning path uh you
get access to integrated labs and
projects for handson experience uh this
is for the folks who have basically
shared that I do I basically cannot get
get job red through a program you know I
don't have that access so this program
provides and I'll be sharing more about
this program by I goha in the upcoming
slides the online virtual classrooms you
get access to with the live instructor
interaction and this program is of eight
months duration uh you can just complete
it by giving 10 to 15 hours per week uh
if schedule uh and timing is an issue
for you so this program is flexible to
fit your schedule and also the
eligibility and prequisites for the
program uh so you may be from a
non-programming background it is not a
necessary or a required skill to have uh
if you have a programming knowledge uh
definitely we cover few basic things
here which I'll be sharing uh basically
how uh you develop your skills here in
through this program and you need to
have a high school diploma or equivalent
and at least 18 years of age uh you need
to be uh at least that and no work
experience is required to take up this
program so these are the I think someone
asked that if do I need to have some
coding or programming language for for
becoming a cloud computing or devop
expert so that b basically answers your
question uh here uh we actually also
cover a lot of these skills step by step
so this program builds your Cloud
develop skills step by step let me
quickly take you through this uh steps
here uh so here U the induction session
for cloud cing boot camp happens and uh
once we go ahead with the foundations
and preparative module here for AWS and
aure uh then we move ahead for AWS Cloud
fundamentals and then we move ahead by
by covering a AWS Solutions architect
and uh then we move on to Microsoft
certified Aur administrator
as104 and uh then we move ahead to
designing Microsoft azuru infrastructure
Solutions e305 so uh this is all covered
in the program step by step and then
then we move on to the devops on AWS and
uh then you get to work on a cloud
computing uh boot cam Capstone project
so we'll be talking about the Capstone
project and other projects in the
upcoming slides uh which basically gets
you job operating uh but here the
electives uh come as a part of the
program but they are optional so here
the electives are from IAT ghati cloud
computing academic master classes which
you get access to uh the office hours
and the project RS and also the
generative AI master class uh as a part
of the program which basically builds
your Cloud devop skill step by step so
the electives uh again like about the
electives they come as a to program they
are optional we do not charge anything
extra for that so you can basically take
it up as per your interest and the tools
and platforms we'll be covering in this
program are Amazon ec2 Amazon uh Dynamo
DB AWS Lambda Amazon S3 and many more uh
tools and platforms which will be
covered in the program I'll be sharing
the link towards the pro uh to the
program uh in in shortly so you can have
a look at it uh thorough look at it as
well so the Capstone project which I
talked about earlier so uh the Capstone
project B mimic real life business
scenarios for two experences which you
can Showcase in your portfolio to
Showcase to your future employees uh
this definitely helps uh for someone
who's coming from a non cloud computing
or DeVos background to show a real time
experience through this Capstone project
you can choose uh one project out of
several domains here uh this basically
involves solving real world business
requirements with Hands-On experiences
so the cap projects uh provide really
great example of your work if you
basically are getting out there and
trying to land the job of your dreams
here so and the industry B based hands
on projects you get to work on for your
portfolio uh the projects which we cover
here are deploy a multitimer web app
using Amazon sqs uh deployment of a
multicloud app uh Aur and ews connection
architecture through a VPC we actually
have done a uh all of these project demo
demo master classes as well just to give
you an overview of uh these projects you
know what happens I'll share the uh
share those webinar links where you can
check out the other the webinars which
we do and check out the old ones as well
in the chat in sometime uh so we Al also
have global leaders as program advisers
here Dr gorov tredi Who is associate
professor uh in the IAT ghati and uh
basically he is uh a part of triple and
a principal investigator in the en ICT
academy uh he makur that simply learn is
delivering as per IAT garti
standard moving on I think someone asked
about the job assist Services uh do we
help with interview preparation do we
help with resume uh prep you know once
uh you are done with the program so we
do that uh so here we have job assist
Services by tyet Inc here uh where you
get access to premium resume rabit job
job portal a resume uh review and
rewrite service and also oneone
interview Service as well so uh you
basically can get access to all of these
job services by Talent
Inc so here uh we have covered the
basically I've talked about the career
skills we have talked about the program
here we have talked about uh what tools
you and platforms you'll be covering in
this program we have talked about how
important it is to have some kind of
experience to show on your portfolio uh
basically when you're trying to go out
there and land a cloud devops job of
your dreams so uh we would love to know
if you are interested in enrolling into
IAT guti's uh program in cloud and
devops this is a professional
certificate program uh and also there's
a bonus offer for attending this webinar
so you can Avail the bonus offer by
clicking on yes on the poll here so I'm
just launching this quick poll to
understand uh your uh interest in
enrolling to the program so you'll be
getting a bonus offer for attending the
uh this webinar and you can Avail it by
clicking on yes here uh as for the
interest you have in enrolling to the
IAT ghati uh Cloud DeVos professional
certificate program so we'll be talking
more about the enrollment steps and
program uh details I'll be sharing the
program l link on the chat here and also
if you have any questions uh we will be
taking those questions as well also uh
even questions after the webinar uh once
you have shared that you're interested
in enrolling into the program through
this poll which you can which I'll be
keeping live for the next 15 seconds as
I'm speaking I see a lot of interest
coming towards enrollment so that's
great uh also not to forget that we have
a bonus offer for attending this webinar
which you can Avail uh by showing us
that uh your interest in this poll here
and also I'll be sharing the link to the
program here as well uh because I know
that folks have joined also uh from
different different countries so uh I'll
just share the link to the program here
as well so you can check out the
professional certificate program in
cloud computing and devops by en ICT
Academy I ghati and uh we would love to
know your interest uh through this quick
poll here which you can see on your
screen would you like to enroll into the
professional certificate program in
cloud computing and devops by e and ICT
Academy IAT
guar also uh we would be also getting to
know your interest basically when do you
plan to enroll so the bonus offer stands
still even after 6 months so if in case
you have not planned uh to join uh the
upcoming cohort immediately so we have
more cohorts you know which come
throughout the year so you basically uh
can use that bonus offer as well for uh
attending uh another cohort which uh is
basically will be upcoming in the
next three to six months as well so I'll
be asking that as well that part of the
question just to understand when do you
plan to basically enroll uh so this will
give us a better better understanding on
when do you plan to enroll into the
program and also Avail the bonus offer
you'll be getting for attending this
webinar so I think I'll just give five
seconds more for the poll here uh for
folks who are still uh I can see the
polls moving still I can see a lot of
interest coming towards the enrollment
side of the program by ghati
here uh for someone uh I can see someone
uh yes you can enroll uh after 4 months
as well so that is not an issue I'll be
uh basically asking that quick poll
question as well when do you plan to
enroll so it will have an option if you
basically are not sure that if you want
to enroll within six months you can
enroll after 6 months and even Avail
this bonus sofware as well you can start
with the a coh which is coming after six
months as well so that is completely
okay
s
awesome uh folks I think I'll just
quickly close this poll in the next 5
seconds so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll and thank you so much for uh
sharing your interest I saw a lot of
interest coming towards the program so
for folks who have shared their interest
let me quickly take you through the
enrollment steps here so we have three
simple easy steps you need to follow uh
so you need to submit an application to
us at ask us at simple.net uh the next
step the application will be going for a
review and based on the eligibility and
prequisites we have shared with you uh
you'll be getting a learning consultant
uh call an offer letter admission offer
letter uh based on uh the details you
have submitted once basically your
application is reviewed I'll be sharing
that email ID uh once I'm basically done
sharing the program fee and the
enrollment schedule uh so in case you
have any questions you can always reach
out to us at ask us at.net about the
program or anything in general if you
want to explore other things as well so
here uh we uh have the program fee here
for the Indian region here so you can
see uh the program fee for this I IT
ghati professional certificate program
in cloud computing and devops is 1 lakh
24,999 including taxes ay and uh I think
someone asked about if there is an Emi
option as AV available as well so they
would like to offer that so we do have
that uh you can just go for financing
avable as low as
4,254 rupees per month and also uh the
upcoming cohort for this one the most
recent one uh the induction start on
29th of November and the classes will be
starting on 2nd of December so in case
you planning to basically join uh like
the upcoming cohort you can basically
let us know through this Sport and also
I think few of the folks asked that
basically if uh at all if I plan to join
after four months uh will the bonus of
real well be yes it will be valid so
I've launched a quick pool to understand
when do you plan to join as I mentioned
earlier that a lot of folks have shared
interest towards enrollment to the I
goti professional certificate program
and cloud computing devops uh we would
love to know that how soon do you plan
to enroll so you can see four quick
options here uh you can select the one
the most suitable for you the first one
immediately second one within three
months third one within six months and
the last one more than 6 months from now
so uh this will actually give us a
better understanding when do we
basically reach out to you with the
offer letter when do simply learns
learning cons reach out to you and also
give you a much more detailed walk
through as required of the program so I
think I'll just while you are sharing
your responses for this pool here I will
also share the email ID which I've
mentioned basically if you need any more
assistance in enrolling to the program
you can reach out to us at ask us at
simple.net uh also as I've mentioned
earlier that we do a lot of these
webinars throughout the month these
interesting webinars uh consisting of
project demos resume review Master Class
interview prep Master Class like this
one we do a lot of career sessions
career indry sessions uh career Trends
so you can basically check out those
upcoming webinars here on this
particular page I've shared the link
here please do check it out in case uh
you are interested in attending more
Cloud uh devops uh sessions and other
other ceg sessions which we cover as
well so I think folks who have shared
their interest towards enrollment I see
that they have already shared the
responses for the poll here how soon do
they plan to enroll so let me quickly
end this poll now and also for folks who
have already shared with us uh when do
you plan to enroll and your interest
towards enrollment we would love to know
if you need any assistance in enrolling
to the program so you can see two quick
options here yes or no and uh this
basically will uh let us know if you
need assist in enrolling into the
program so please choose uh as per your
preference here meanwhile I'll
just quickly
share the program link once again on the
chat here in case you want to go through
the program link here
from for your own region here as well in
much more
detail and as I mentioned earlier in
case you have any questions uh you can
let us know uh on on this mail which
I've shared with you on the chat ask us
at simply. net also for just to mention
that the cads which we take up only have
25 to 30 folks per CAD in order to make
sure that you're getting all the
attention that is required and uh so we
have limited seats for cohart also on
the
program aesome I think I can see most of
the folks have shared responses for the
poll so once again uh thank you so much
for for uh sharing uh your uh responses
with us uh we were not able to take all
the questions here we have gotten here
because it was an interview prep master
class and also the speaker had limited
time uh but we'll be coming up with more
such master classes you can check out
the link I've shared on the chat here in
case you want to explore the uh other
webinars as well and uh even the
previous webinars you can find the
recordings there as well so thank you so
much once again for joining the session
thank you uh please please do let us
know the postar surve how did you like
the session and ALS also put down your
full name for the webinar certificate of
the session so thank you so much thank
you
I